manqu en juin et juillet dernier on va
revenir sur cette affaire le réalisateur
Nicolas Bodos a été accusé de viol et
d'agression sexuelle par trois femmes
une enquête préliminaire avait été
ouverte ces trois femmes ont témoigné
après que l'animateur é accusé
regardez depuis plusieurs mois Nicolas
bedo s'est visé par une enquête il
s'agit d'une enquête qui a été ouverte
le 5 juillet dernier pour viol et
agression sexuelle alors que l'homme est
réalisateur sera prochainement convoqué
devant le tribunal correctionnel pour
agression sexuelle en état d'ivresse
dans une boîte de nuit dans le cadre
d'une autre affaire plusieurs femmes ont
en juillet dernier porté de lourdes
accusations à son encontre il lui aurait
demandé avec insistance de monter dans
sa chambre elle aaurait refusé Nicolas
Bedos a été entendu la semaine dernière
en tant que suspect libre dans cette
enquête pour viol myiam Palomba nous
explique tout ce soir dans
TPMP merci Miriam alors Nicolas Bedos
entendu dans le cadre d'une enquête pour
viol oui alors il a été la semaine
dernière entendu dans dans une dans une
enquête pour viol et agression sexuelle
par le premier district de de police Jud
re c'est en fait il faut que je vous
explique un peu l'histoire parce que en
fait l'effit remonte au 1er et 2 juin
dernier ou dans une discothèque
parisienne sauvage pour pour pas la
citer Nicolas B c'est une discothèque
c'est tu saquel c'est ouais c'est quoi
sauvage sauvage d'accord voilà dans le
quartier déal donc là Nicolas bedose qui
était visiblement assez é méché aurait
agressé une jeune femme de 25 ans il
serait allé sur la piste de danse il lui
aurait mis la main entre les jambes et
du coup elle l'aurait repoussé il elle
lui aurait dit mais tu es tu es fou toi
et cetera et puis elle aurait dit tu es
fou
dis-moi dis-moi c'était ma cousine ou
quoi dis-moi tu es fou toi ou quoi je
vais desescinter tu es
fou qu'elle aurait dit tu es fou voilà
c'est ça donc elle lui a dit tu es fou
va-ton et cetera et puis du coup elle a
été portée plainte le 12 juin et le 22
juin Nicolas Bedos est donc mis en garde
à vue suite à cette histoire alors là il
reconnaît pas vraiment les fait dit que
c'est que s'il y a eu effectivement à
touchement c'était accidentel il était
bourré et cetera il s'excuse donc là
l'OPJ lui remet une convocation il
devait être jug il doit être jugé pour
ces faits d'agression sexuel sous
l'effet de l'alcool au mois de février
prochain les choses auraient pu
s'arrêter là sauf que trois femmes ont
ont envoyé des signalements au parquet
et le parquet comme les fait pour tous
ne sont pas
prescrit a décidé de prendre l'affaire
en main même si elle ces trois femmes
n'ont pas déposé plainte et ce sont des
faits qui dont certains sont qualifié de
viol d'accord ouis donc c'est c'est
sérieux oui c'est très sérieux alors il
y a a une jeune enfin une jeune femme
maintenant elle a 50 ans qui qui parle
alors c'est elle qui qui parle de viol
les faits remontent dans les anné en
1999 elle était amie avec Nicolas Bedos
il l'invite à une soirée la soirée se
continue il lui propose d'aller chez lui
chez ses parents à ne et là il lui
propose de monter dans sa chambre il lui
aurait proposé de monter dans sa chambre
c'est ce qu'elle dit euh évidemment elle
refuse parce qu'elle sent bien que
quelque chose se passe il l'aurait
attrapé par la gorge en lui disant mais
tu te prends pour qui toi tu es quand
même pas Catherine de neuve là-dessus il
l'aurait forcé à aller dans sa chambre
et là aurait eu un acte non de sexuel
non consenti avec avec cette jeune femme
il y a une autre femme aussi qui qui
parle euh qui qui a qui a fait un
signalement en racontant que elle elle
était adolescente au moment des faits
hein c'était en 2016 c'était dans dans
une maison de vacances où elle était
invitée par Nicolas Bedos et sa compagne
de l'époque et là pareil alors là c'est
plus du du ressort de l'agression
sexuelle il aurait pareil enfin il
aurait voulu l'embrasser de force elle
se serait débattu et puis bon ça ça en
serait resté là et il y a aussi un
troisième témoignage d'une autre jeune
femme qui là explique que elle c'est
dans le cadre d'une soirée où il y avait
des artistes une soirée un peu cinéma un
peu showbiz et cetera et que là pareil
il l'aurait forcé à aller à la coincer
dans les toilettes et qui pareil il
aurait voulu l'embrasser il lui aurait
touché le ventre et cetera enfin il y
aurait eu des attouchements donc ces
trois signalements qui sont quand même
des défaits assez graves le parquet a
décidé de pas les prendre à la légère et
et aujourd'hui entamé une enquête alors
c'est une audition libre pourquoi parce
que contrairement à la garde à vue il
aurait pu partir à tout moment mais
effectivement dans cette dans cette
histoire il est quand même considéré
comme suspect d'accord Gill c'est une
circonstance aggravante par rapport à la
première affaire et le jugement en
février parfois on on pense que non mais
le le fait de commettre une agression
sexuelle en état d'ébriété est une
circonstance aggravante et vous pouvez
risquer jusqu'à 7 ans de prison hein son
procès en février il risque gros cyil
alors euh mon Stéphane on qui sort du
silence il est accusé de violence
conjugale par plusieurs de ses excagnes
mais on a des infos Gill vous avez des
infos exclusives vraiment Gill et ce
sont des vrais infos hein Gill vraiment
vraiment moi aussi j'ai des vrais infos
oui mais lui
ili il a vas-y donne tes infos mais lui
il a vraiment eu il a il il a d doute
pas que vous AZ voà allez-y alors
allez-y parce que on aura les infos de
alors je sais pas si les gens ont vu
mais là depuis quelques jours hein
depuis samedi du silence Stéphan Plaz
sorti du silence alors il fait de de de
jolies phrases sur Instagram où il
remercie son public il se il se la joue
à moitié philosophe et cetera là
aujourd'hui il vient de dire que euh
voilà là c'est la reine pour enfoncer
les gens pas moitié philosophe attend tu
attends la suite je te promets attends
la suite et donc là il remercie son
public et il dit que voilà il est
confiant que la justice euh va va sauver
son son honneur et cetera et pourquoi il
dit ça pourquoi depuis quelques jours
Stéphane Plazza revient un peu sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est parce que
effectivement moi les infos que j'ai
c'est que l'enquête avance plutôt en sa
faveur ouais tu vois c'est positif euh
avance plutôt en sa faveur et que
l'histoire du complot semble vraiment se
se dessiner et comme vous le savez il y
a trois plaintes aussi pour harcèlement
qui ont été déposé par des jeunes femmes
qui se sont dites harcelées par les
victimes supposées de Stéphane Plaza et
du coup comme la la l'enquête avance
plutôt dans son sens faut savoir quand
même que Stéphane plazade n'a toujours
pas été entendu par la police donc ils
estiment que les faits sont pas
aussifin ça demande pas une alors Meriam
Gilles a a des infos exclusives qui
vient d'avoir de de cet après-midi oui
alors l'enquête effectivement contre
Stéphane Plaza avance mais elle avance
moins vite que l'enquête qui est liée à
la plainte que Stéphane Plaza a déposé
pour cyber harcèlement et là les
enquêteurs sont en train de remonter les
faux profils parce que ce sont des faux
profils selon lui qui ont commencé à le
harceler donc il faut maintenant établir
si ces faux profils sont liés aux femmes
qui ont porté plainte contre lui ça
c'est une possibilité alors évidemment
s'il a commis des violences il doit être
condamné il y a pas de souci mais il y a
une 4ème plainte qui vient d'être
déposée qui est très sérieuse contre les
femmes qui l'ont cyber harcelé ça fait
maintenant quatre plaintes et ces
plaintes elles étaient au départ contre
X mais elles portent les noms des gens
qui sont derrière les faux profils
et si jamais il s'avère Infiné que
Stéphane Plaza n'est pas condamné que
par exemple on a voulu le harcelé qu'on
a voulu lui nuire ça pourrait coûter
très cher aux gens qui l'ont cber
harcelé pourquoi parce que les
franchisés en ce moment sont en chute
libre et ces franchisés il verent 8 % de
redevance et ces franchisés ont décidé
d'attaquer d'attaquer les gens qui ont
cyberhcelé si jamais ces gens sont
retrouvés et si jamais Stéphane Plaza
gagne ce volet là ces gens vont être
attaqués par les franchisés et ça va
leur coûter une fortune parce que le
préjudice économique le préjudice
économique est c'est tout à fait
normal une source de dossier m'a dit si
jamais il est établi que c'était
vraiment du cyber harcèlement et si on
retrouve derrière les faux profils les
identités ce qui est possible ces
gens-là vont se retrouver sur la paille
donc c'est une affaire qui peut se
retourner c'est une affaire où il y aura
très bientôt du nouveau et les sommes
vont se chiffrer en millions d'euros
c'estàdire qu'on va demander à des gens
si ces gens sont retrouvés de payer des
millions d'euros de dommage donc voilà
Stéphane Plaza en ce moment encore une
fois je ne préjuge pas de l'issue du de
la première plainte lui euh la situation
et voilà il va il va très mal il est il
est isolé il tente de se reconstruire
évidemment c'est difficile il suit ça de
très près mais le volet cyberhcèlement
prend une dimension que l'on ne
soupçonnait pas Cyril voilà très bien
merci il y a des sommes énormes derrière
merci à vous deux en tout cas merci qui
reviendra demain parce qu'on a d'autres
infos people qui tombe et demain il y a
un très gros dossier qui va tomber